there's currently lots of confusion and
debate over who is a socialist and this
has become super prominent in right-wing
political discourse as of late you might
remember that at the latest state of the
union address Donald Trump even loudly
proclaimed that the United States is
never going to be a socialist country
and I want to dig into this today first
of all as I've said before Trump can't
actually control whether the US ever
becomes a socialist country and you
can't control what happens after his
presidency but the most important
reaction to have when Trump loudly
proclaims that is that there's no big
clamoring for actual socialism from
anyone in power in the United States the
furthest left ideas that are prominent
in the u.s. from elected officials are
socially democratic ideas with the
tiniest sprinkling of people in Congress
who actually are open to the idea of
socializing the means of production but
basically the furthest left ideas that
are part of the dialogue are social
democratic ideas number two - very very
crudely summarize it socialism sort of
split off in the late 19th century one
direction was the Stalinist Leninist
line which became communistic and then
there's the social democracy line which
became most prominently early or late in
the 19th century the Swedish Social
Democratic Party but that doesn't
actually matter because this is a known
tactic the tactic is smear as communist
anything that is socially Democratic
that that's the the tactic that we've
seen for a very long time Edward
Herrmann and Noam Chomsky write about
this in their 1988 book manufacturing
consent we have to be able to really
think about this we have to separate our
personal beliefs from factual history as
people know I'm not a communist but I'm
acknowledging that communism has been
smeared as a propaganda method dating
all the way back to the early 20th
century in the United States and the
reason that this can happen the reason
that social democracy can
smeared under the umbrella of communism
is because a lot of people don't really
understand what social democracy is
versus socialism versus communism so
it's a tactic that works really really
well I don't want to give a full history
lesson here and we've gone into the
differences between socialism and
communism and social democracy but what
you have to understand is that most of
the American left is not socialist and
it's also not communist to the extent
that they even know the differences
between those ideologies and social
democracy because the right accuses
people like me Social Democrats of being
communists or socialists we immediately
end up on the defensive we on the left
end up having to defend what is
socialism or communism we end up miss
handling it we end up sounding sometimes
like the anti-communist reactionaries
that have been in the United States
since the early 20th century when no
one's actually talking about communism
so it's a really good tactic that the
right uses it's a brilliant smear you
say hey you know what um we could learn
a lot from the health care system of the
UK or from Canada or Sweden or
Switzerland and in comes the right and
they say that is a communist idea that's
a socialist idea the next part of the
conversation when someone says let's see
how we can improve our healthcare system
the next part of the conversation should
be you know what we should we should
discuss is Medicare for all the best
path forward or would we be better off
with a nationalized care delivery system
and a nonprofit health insurance
apparatus or would the german system be
better than the swiss system or what
elements of the canadian system would be
good that's the the way the conversation
should go you often can't even get there
because in comes the right saying that
socialist that's communist it's a
government takeover it's anti-american
and what the left ends up having to do
or ends up doing anyway is arguing about
whether health care for all is socialist
it's the wrong debate it
worked for 100 years it fragments the
left particularly because it makes the
small portion of the left that is
actually socialistic come out and say we
are socialists and that's a good thing
that's not the majority of the left the
demonization of communism might not
really seem important to Social
Democrats because we're not communists
but it's very damn or damaging because
it creates this sort of false dichotomy
between Communists and anti-communists
the reality is there's no threat of
communism in the United States Social
Democrats who believe in a mixed economy
and healthcare for all don't think about
communism very much what we're talking
about is modernizing our basic systems
the way that many rich countries have
done but when they draw the line as
either you're a communist or you're an
anti-communist
it makes the Left split and it makes the
left start to sound like reactionaries
and we end up losing so there's two
sides to this number one we should
accept that either way they are going to
smear Social Democratic ideas as
communist ideas these are capitalist
ideas they exist in capitalist systems
whether it's universal health care
tuition free college living wages they
will say these are communist ideas they
are not we should expect that and we
should know how to deal with it but the
one word of caution to the left is we
also shouldn't help them out by saying
we are democratic socialists when we are
Social Democrats there's a number of
elected officials in the Democratic
Party that have made this mistake they
call themselves Democratic socialists
when they are not that makes it easier
for the right to fracture the left for
the right to smear the left as
socialists
let's not make it easier for them let's
call ourselves Social Democrats if that
look that's what we are if you're a
socialist by all means call yourself a
socialist there is no advantage to using
the term Democratic Socialist if it
doesn't actually apply it just makes the
right smear tactics more effective but
understand this has been going on for a
very very long time and
should not fall for it